more now on breaking news coming out of
brunswick georgia today where three
white men were found guilty of murdering
25-year-old ahmad arbury travis
mcmichael who shot and killed aubry was
found guilty on all nine counts this
means he could face life in prison now
greg mcmichael and william roddy bryan
were also found guilty of murder and
prosecutors are seeking life in prison
without parole for all three of those
men
reaction to the closely watched case is
pouring in what do you think this
verdict means not only for the black
community of course but also for the
country as a whole having watched this
trial play out and watch the video
evidence play out as well
i think for some people in the country
they're recognizing that this is not
going to be like the 1930s 40s 50s 60s
right
i think unfortunately for a lot of
people
though
we're seeing them realize how much
public pressure it took you know there
was a comment made to me that yeah this
is great
but the problem is that before that
video went public they didn't look like
they were going to charge them
it shouldn't take social media and all
eyes upon you for justice of any kind to
happen for accountability to occur and
that's this feels like
a conviction that happened because they
had no other choice
and given that we are seeing reactions
pouring in this afternoon i'm curious
what you have found to be a misstep in
the discourse and analysis so far is
there anything that you've seen that you
just feel is not an accurate or um
potentially
sound
analysis of this verdict today
i think anyone who thinks this is proof
that things have changed
is ignoring a lot of context right
this case
isn't a dictate of how the cases are
going to go anywhere else this case
isn't even an analysis of how the rest
of america is going to react because
what i keep coming back to the reason we
have that video is because they
released that video of themselves they
thought they genuinely thought it proved
that they hadn't done anything wrong
and there are people still arguing that
there must have been more to the story
well why was he in this building under
construction why was he running
as though black people don't just exist
in neighborhoods and do things like job
and be curious
i would love to hear what you think too
about
the reaction to the verdict and how that
potentially contrasts with some of the
jargon that we heard particularly from
the defense during the trial just two
days ago on this show we were talking
about some of the remarks from defense
attorney attorneys that led ahmad arby's
mother to exit the courtroom
how do you square the defense's remarks
uh regarding ahmad with today's verdict
i think the defense was doing their job
however
abominable i find their job to be in
this case
but i want to say this
at some point the defense attorney very
clearly was okay with re-traumatizing
a murder victim's mother
um was okay with defending people who
had committed a lynching and total video
view
and was going to stand up in front of a
camera and either
do his work and
it's not personal or he genuinely
believes it and we saw people
really trying to argue that
well
you know he was she was running he
should have stopped should have
explained what he was doing there he
should have been sure it should have
at some point in there you have to stop
and ask yourself
at what point do we say wait a minute
it's not on the victim or the victim's
family or the victim support system to
make it easier for the people who killed
the victim to get away with her
and obviously the state trial is
finished we're just awaiting sentencing
but i do want to look ahead with you to
the federal hate crimes trial which will
begin in february do you feel that
today's verdict could have an impact on
that trial
oh i think that the federal hate crimes
trial
i always expected that to be the one
where we might see consequences just
because of what we saw in the video and
just because of their other rhetoric
um i assume that it will have an impact
i also suspect though that
they may suddenly decide they want to
plead to the feds rather than face
another lifestyle
right right and we're already hearing
that uh there's going to be an appeal as
well potentially i also sticking with
federal responses want to talk about
president biden's reaction uh in in
response to the written house verdict he
said the jury system works and we have
to abide by it
what did you make of that reaction and
i'm curious also if you could
tell me what grade you would give the
white house's response to these trials
that we've seen over the course of the
past couple weeks
uh is it
is there something below an f like what
are we doing is there a z grade for this
because
while i understand that he is the
president and this is sort of what the
speech writers have come up with and
this is where you know governing the
entire country
um the jury system didn't really work in
the red house trial in my opinion okay
granted we do really love the idea of
the jury system working
but if you can recognize that what the
jury did here wasn't enough and not
enough has occurred you probably should
have been able to recognize that what
happened with written house was also not
enough
yeah thank you for explaining that um in
our final minute together mickey i'm
curious if there's anything else that
you are looking ahead
to uh in terms of what this verdict
could mean not just for the black
community but again for the country as a
whole i know you mentioned that this
isn't something to be
optimistic about in your view um
how do you think it affects our country
going forward then
i think unless our country is willing to
admit that this was a lynching and that
it took a lynching on video for them to
even consider a conviction
we're not really moving that fast
america spent more time with lynching
being legal than uh we ever want to
admit
and we are still to some degree saying
well yes okay this time we're gonna
we're gonna hold this person accountable
but we're not gonna hold the system that
made them think committing a lynching
was acceptable accountable we're not
going to look at the people who would
have enabled them to get away with it if
they could
we're just going to say this time the
lynching didn't happen see progress i
would like us to not get to a point
where we have to see a video of someone
being murdered in cold blood before we
acknowledge that they probably shouldn't
have been killed for running
absolutely mickey really appreciate you
joining us and giving us all of your
analysis and thoughts on this verdict
thank you so much and again i'll remind
our audience that was mickey kendall
she's an author and diversity consultant
as